good morning believe nation today's
message is be patient over to you ll
cool j I wake up every mood ladies
friends new TV go where I come from
people very passionate hot glue and what
they want a nap I needed right away
everyone's looking for a shortcut
sometimes it's sometimes an indirect
route is the quickest way to get there
sometimes you got to take a little
longer to achieve the things you will
achieve the life so don't be in a hurry
be patient be patient everybody wants
everything now even our society this
instant gratification Instagram is this
be patient I think it's important to
remember that needs to be patient but
not lazy I think a lot of people make
that connection between the two where
you're waiting for something to happen
and until it happens just don't do
anything else the key is that you hustle
while you wait waiting is a part of the
game but it does mean you're not doing
anything while you wait and you're
developing other opportunities while you
want you hustle while you wait so as an
example I wanted to grow this salsa
dance business right I want to go to the
studio I want to get lots more students
coming in and want to grow a customer
base I want us to be well known one of
the things that I might do is take out a
direct mail campaign ok I'm going to do
a direct mail campaign blast cards to
everybody who's within a ten-mile radius
of this studio that's going to take some
time right it's going to take some time
to develop the artwork to then figure
out how we're going to distribute them
to then get them into the hands of the
people living in neighborhoods to then
wait for the next scheduled to open up
for people to sign up to them wait for
them to actually come and buy a class
and then we've them that you come and
put their money down and show up for the
class right that's a process it takes
time I need to wait for that to happen
but while I'm waiting for them to happen
I'm not just sitting on my hands I'm
doing other things because my goal is to
grow this business so I'm going to be
making YouTube videos I'm going to be
improving the customer experience I'm
going to be improving the location and
the environment I'm going to be looking
at what is the signage that you have
coming out here I'm gonna be looking at
what else can I do with social media
what else going to do to get into
mainstream media I'm going to be
hustling while I'm waiting so waiting
this part of the game but don't be lazy
don't just wait on one thing to happen
start other projects why are you waiting
for the first thing that happen hustle
while you wait don't be lazy believe so
the question of day today for you guys
is two parts one are you patient and to
what you do when you're being impatient
and waiting for something to happen the
liquid in the comments below on the
Jordan discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events Reza